[Music]
okay everyone so this is my
spoiler review of fear street part 2
1978. this again is directed by lee
yanyik
and it is written again by lee yanyik
but this time
a different writing partner with her
that is with zach ulkowicz
now what a world of difference the
second writing partner she has used on
this film has made compare the first
writing partner because you can see this
script is way more grounded
it doesn't have as many loose ends it
makes character
first which is always a winning formula
and it has a bunch of things that are
set up and that are paid off
so that was the first noticeable
difference i saw in this film compared
to the first one that was a big
improvement
what also was incredible to me was this
performance of an actress i had no
prior knowledge about which was emily
rudd who plays
cindy berman here and she to me fully
committed to this part
and it's such a good performance because
it's not just her
acting ability but her physical acting
here the whole
thing about her she is this character
and i was so impressed by that and i
thought that also took this film up a
notch with having such a strong lead
performance
and even though we get the big reveal at
the end that c berman is actually ziggy
and not
cindy the movie really is cindy's film
here
so it was so important that whoever they
cast it as cindy really had to bring it
and she does
and i thought they did this misdirect
really well with having that reveal that
gillian jacobs character of c
berman is actually ziggy in the end
because the way she behaves in current
day
it would make sense for it to be cindy
because cindy's the more
uptight one and it matches the more with
what's happening here with c berman but
it also makes sense at ziggy
because we see ziggy changes by what
happens to her sister which we're going
to get to so it made sense and it worked
really well i think
and what i'm talking about with payoffs
coming from little things that are set
up and we don't forget about them which
would happen a little bit in the first
film here it doesn't happen
for example i was worried about when
cindy actually
first sees now this nurse attacks her
boyfriend tommy
and she freezes up and doesn't do
anything and you're like okay that was
weird like
they better address that and they do and
that comes in when
cindy talks about how she has that
problem later on to alice in the cave
saying
she froze up and no i she doesn't
believe she's able to kill tommy if need
be when alice asked her so it sets
up this character arc that's so well for
cindy that eventually she will get to
that point where she does kill
tommy and grows out of that hesitation
and the strength of this story in
general
is this sister story between ziggy and
cindy and ziggy being this
free spirit and she's a believer right
she believes in all the witch stuff she
is right at the end of the day about
what she thought was going on with
shadyside where
cindy is the complete opposite she's
uptight she's a prude
and it's interesting as the film goes on
we learn more about cindy that cindy
used to be that way where she wasn't
always this prude or trying to be
perfect
and then you get a great moment with
alice when she explains to her
that i was doing that because i was
trying to be perfect because i didn't
want to believe
because she knew shadyside was cursed
but she thought this is the only way to
not actually have to deal with that
and it ties in well having the story
about the parents and splitting up
because that was really what split these
two sisters up
to this story where we start but it
beautifully wraps at the end
because when they're getting chopped up
and it's such a powerful moment
they literally have a line like we're
not gonna split again i thought that was
so so powerful so every little beat here
is adding up to a great finale and
everything is earned so it's really
tight riding here
and that doesn't just stop with having
cindy's character get all this character
tension it obviously happens with ziggy
but
it really importantly for the whole
trilogy gets us to know nick good now
who he's just the sheriff in the first
film you don't know much about him
purposely but this really explains he
gives so much depth to his character
that really he's the catalyst behind all
of this that
nick makes this selfish choice by the
pressures from filling in his father's
footsteps who used to be sheriff
and those pressures explaining his
motivation to go that way and
to be in denial about everything and
that will keep the chain going of shady
side and the curse and he's responsible
for that so i thought that was really
interesting they did a good job making
that clear and what i also thought was
really smart about how they set up where
our characters
were was having ziggy with nick so it
will set up for their story in the
trilogy and
clearly set it up for the third film
where we end this film where ziggy
actually calls nick and they have to
kind of deal with this now
in the present day about him pretty much
ruining everything but
i also like on the other side of it that
they had alice
with cindy because alice was that
character to push cindy to her former
self and to get her out of being this
uptight
person and i thought that really worked
well in the cave and that there was
meaning to all of their dialogue beats
and they also gave little attention
to alice and having alice have this
story about having a troubled past and
that she cut herself and that wasn't all
just fun for her that you know cindy was
saying she was having so
i thought they really did pay attention
to that and left having thin characters
like i said the first of them had
many thin characters probably besides
kate where this everyone kind of had a
little bit of meat to them
now casting wise the only thing i do
really appreciate
when they cast younger versions of a
character we've seen their older self
like a nick good that they look somewhat
you know of a resemblance here but
i felt you know this would have been the
perfect character the younger actor to
play
you know a guy who's supposed to be
justin thorough in the future not
ashley zuckerman it actually just didn't
look at all like him to me so i thought
that was a little bit of a miss but not
the biggest deal in the world
i also you know wasn't a fan of this
hippie character they had this character
kind of felt like some of the problems
people had with the first film about not
being totally
vibe of 90s behavior of people in it and
that he still felt like maybe it was gen
z's playing people in the 90s but
this was more of just the writing where
they actually had her say the word
shagadelic and this wasn't something
people said in the 70s this was made by
mike myers and austin powers that was
exaggerating that type behavior so
unless this character took a time
machine and watched austin powers it
made no sense that she would say that so
that was a big miss for me as well but
again these are tiny things where these
were more the glaring issues in the
first film and i remember too a big
complaint about the first one which i
agree with is that it seems like no one
was around and everyone disappeared and
it just
didn't make sense in the reality of the
situation but they did a good job in
this film when
you start feeling that way where no
one's around they're showing you the
counselors leading all the other campers
into cabins now you could say maybe we
could have seen an adult or two
i agree with that but still they did a
good job of reminding you like okay no
everyone's being put into one location
that's why
our main players are alone so this
character of tommy slater the big reveal
is that
he becomes this camp nightwing killer
possessed by sarah fear and i
interview the actor of tommy slater so
make sure to check out that
link below it's really good time and
what's cool about this character he's
very
inspired obviously by jason from friday
the 13th movies even the theme music
they use
is very close to that and it works
really well and they do not shy away
from the gore here they give him a bunch
of great killings which i love
i think his best kill was actually when
he
kills the guy in the bathroom when
they're pulling the rope to bring the
girls up
on the bucket and it was just amazing
that slice of the head i thought that
was
really cool and it wasn't like afraid to
go there and that's props the director
of lee yenyik where she has such a skill
of you know building suspense and
letting it go and going for it like she
has a belief in what she's making i feel
and she avoids boredom in those
sequences because again
as i've said before slasher horror is my
least favorite subgenre of horror
because i think they get repetitive and
they get boring and they drag sequences
out too long but these aren't drag to me
i think all the sequences with the
slashing they move at a good pace
the music's really good and it's set up
and blocked well
i'm also happy that they fixed another
complaint i had had about the first film
was that we didn't see enough reactions
to deaths and that like characters
forgot someone's significant died where
here
immediately alice addresses her
boyfriend arnie getting an axe to the
face
the next scene so i thought that was
really well done they even addressed
cindy a lot talking about how her
boyfriend's become
possessed and they had such important
just scenes with
ziggy and nick good that are really
going to be the meat of this trilogy
because
it's her thinking this guy who she's
falling for and he's fallen for her
really does believe in her and deep down
he does believe her
right but he doesn't go there he won't
do the right thing and he
lets the pressure of what he's supposed
to be of the sheriff
take control of his choices and they
give enough attention to show that and
that
how heartbroken ziggy will be by the end
of this one of my favorite sequences
that i thought was the creepiest of the
trilogy so far was when alice goes down
into the cave and there's that blob and
when she touches the blob you got the
heartbeat
sounds coming in at a good timing it's
eerie it's creepy looking with the flies
but i love this sequence of all the
shady side killers and we'll see a lot
of these killers later on at the hanging
tree and that final big moment but i
really want to see more of this
kid with a baseball bat he's to me the
coolest looking killer but they're
clearly setting up or they could make
you know more fear street films for sure
based on all these shady sidekillers so
i think it's smart they're kind of
making like the books a franchise out of
all these killers
and just catching things already we know
cyrus miller the pastor is going to be
our shady side killer for the third film
in 1666 but when alice was running
through these caves you know she's
seeing kids with her eyes taken out
which we know is what he does
and we even see what looks like the
twins that were in kate's house from the
first film
so that's really interesting now another
thing i just wish was in this film
and at least like the first film it
wasn't trying to throw a bunch of jokes
i didn't land this one doesn't really
try too much to do that but
i wish it did have more humor kind of
like the humor we saw in it which is
another radar film that's horror
starring kids but something that had
some more
jokes that were funny in it and i think
we got a little bit of that
when maybe the only time i laughed in
the film was when ziggy's letting
sheila out of the outhouse sheila slaps
her and then ziggy punches her
and then she's like oh [ __ ] like she
didn't even do that and drops her to the
toilet but i think
that's what we need a little bit more of
but that's also me being nitpicking it's
not totally necessary but to make this
like an
ultimate amazing film i think i wish
they tried a little more humor here but
it's better than
trying it with every line like they did
in the first film and when i'm talking
about great suspense
this leads to great suspense because
again my favorite kill when
tommy comes in here slices the guy's
head who's pulling the rope with ziggy
it leads to a perfect moment now
where ziggy is running with nick good
and we get a payoff which i'm talking
about here with how she hates snakes and
the snakes that's what crawls on her
this is a great suspenseful moment with
the killer after them and they perfectly
place
cindy and alice away from them but
getting them
to make sense to get together at the end
for our final act
and this scene right after works great
you're getting all these great horror
suspense sequences because you get carry
on away with some which actually really
worked here i didn't feel like the music
was as forced as the first film which
was good and it wasn't used as much it
was also good it relied more on its
really good score
and this made sense so in this scene
because we didn't have really much other
scenes with slashing in that type of
music and
i love how they built it up where you
had cindy trying to get in
screaming the music's covering her voice
and ziggy's there with the killer
and ziggy made the origin of him having
the sack on his head which i thought was
cool and we get our big
moment of character change and payoff
when cindy stabs
tommy this is something she didn't think
she was capable of and now she was this
was
change and growth in her character and i
also got a little vibe of a series i
love the haunting philhouse where
we start to wrap up the story with the
sisters when they're apologizing to each
other
i thought worked really well and we hear
that kind of haunting philos piano play
which will be
later on in our big finale which we'll
get to but when they put all together
to set up our final act here that they
need to get this hand to the body at the
hanging tree this sets up my favorite
sequence yet in either of these films i
thought it was brilliant one i thought
the score was incredible when they're
running to the hanging tree but having
all these killers come after them it was
so
intense and them to have to bury this is
how you do suspense i mean you can't
really do it any better but not only
that it has a lot of character weight
here of what's going to happen with
these two sisters and their story going
forward
and the most important moment here is
because remember
cindy felt awful about not believing her
sister and
not being really there for her and cindy
makes the ultimate sacrifice in the day
pushing a killer away from ziggy and
that was a huge moment which added to
the emotional moment where i teared a
little bit
gotta be honest you know i always admit
when that happens and i did hear and
that's really awesome that i did that's
effective storytelling because it really
hits when they're both there getting
slashed together i think that's like a
memorable moment i always remember in
film like i thought that was really blew
me away i was like wow okay fierce
street like this is amazing like and
having like i said that hill house s
music playing the piano and the best
line of the film with cindy saying
nothing will pull us apart and ziggy
says
never again talking about again what
happened with their parents doing that
for them
and that comes full weight now where
they're not going to do that to each
other again and it shows
that beautiful overhead shot of them
reaching for each other wow
and we get the reveal now that ziggy's
actually see berman
now i did kind of want maybe a little
explanation why her name was c
berman and current day because it kind
of felt like was that just to cheat the
audience but maybe i can excuse it as
you know she is undercover so she didn't
want people knowing her name's christine
and present day
maybe we'll get an answer even next film
so i'll hold off on railing into that
but i will say it doesn't make sense
that josh says here in present day
wait you're ziggy it's like come on so
you're telling me
that see birmingham present day was
telling the story all and like literally
not saying her name to them like and
mentioning she's iggy
one of them like wait which sister are
you like are you city like come on
that's a little much
but this is really good this last
voiceover by gillian jacobs who does a
really good job here doing a serious
role and she's like cindy my sister
sacrificed herself for nothing told
everyone's story no one believed me and
that's when they're like well what about
nick and he
again deep down knows she was right but
he goes into denial mode cause he's
gotta live his destiny as a sheriff so
again it really makes you kind of not
like nick at all here and it's like you
almost want him to get it in the third
film i do at least
and it's a great song they don't just
put the man who sold the world by david
bowie for no reason one it's connecting
because it's david bowie we learned
christine's a big fan because her dog's
name is major tom
alluding to david bowie here and that
song minnesota world is about
a man who no longer recognizes himself
and feels awful about it
so this exactly is nick at our current
state at the end of this film so
that was set up in the first shot
because they played that song of the
movie and then it
comes around here and then you get why
they chose that song so it connects
really nicely here between the two films
where
dina is like we found that body we're
looking for in 78 that wasn't under the
hanging tree
and now they're going to check to see if
that hand's there and it connects well
to that they built them all over that
hanging tree but we got really exciting
set up here because christine ends up
calling nick so
they're gonna talk which is gonna be
exciting but the big moment is dina's
nose starts to bleed when she put her
hand
on the hand of sarah fear and the body
and
we get this crazy reveal that she's now
sarah fear in 1666 and you're like what
and what's really exciting about that
cliffhangers when they show the clip for
the third movie we're seeing now all our
characters coming back so
everyone here from you know fear street
one and two they're back so
we know so many of them died so to see
them kind of in a new form is gonna be
really cool
i'm very excited for number three and we
know that pastor
cyrus miller is gonna be the villain in
the third film and that he takes out
eyes of kids so should be pretty crazy
if they decide to go there i hope they
do but this film shocked me because i
thought the first one was okay
you know and a lot of people were really
hard on it but i did see some critics
who saw this one saying
you know two is going to be a step up
but then i saw some that said they
didn't like to but i thought this was
amazing like i i'm it was one of my
shockers for the year because i was
expecting these some films to be really
good but then the first one was
you know decent to me so then i brought
my expectations down for the next two
okay maybe there isn't that high of a
ceiling but this was it i mean this
is how you do a slasher horror film and
it has
great attention to character you get
your payoffs and the suspense is awesome
the score is awesome so i'm giving this
one
a 9.4 and i think that
it's gonna hold up this film that you
can even watch this one on its own i
think it's gonna be tough for number
three to live up to this
but i think again i gotta give a shout
out to emily rudd because we know sadie
sync is good we know gillian jacobs are
great and we went into this expecting
great performances from them but it's
always a treat when there's a surprise
performance that almost steals a show
and that is emily rudd here so
really really well done and if you
enjoyed my review
here you can check out my review of the
first film if you didn't see that
already and
i will be reviewing part three obviously
with a big interview with olivia welch
herself so you're not going to want to
miss that
so make sure to subscribe and please
follow me at st varley show on twitter
instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time